welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike Hummer
this is a very special edition it's the
April Fool's Day edition be going over a
lava games and all be bad all right so
here we go so the first game is from one
of my favorite players of all time
Owen Oh bidding all right so he was
playing black in this position it was
the first round of the Thanksgiving open
played in 2013 keep in mind this has a
time control of over two hours all right
so white is Fred Smith rated a thousand
and Owen bidding is playing black thank
you all right so everything so far so
good
Owen decides to play g6 to get us Bishop
out that way Fred decides he wants to go
on the attack right away with h4 all
right so Owen has none of that so he
plays h5 white develops his bishop black
brings his knight out to f6 to attack
the up pawn here so white defends it so
Owen decides he's going to take the pawn
and Knight takes back so now why do you
think Owen did that he knew Knight takes
pawn Knights going to take Knight back
but Owen think he has a tactic here okay
so what is the tactic the pawn fork very
good d5 but if we could calculate just
another move do you think that this pawn
fork would actually accomplish you know
what he wants to do like get a piece the
answer is no because white could simply
play Bishop to b5 check all right but
this is April Fool so white decides not
that not to play the check he decides
bring us Queen
- e - alright oh and B you knowin he's
like well you know you're still in the
fork I only have to take it I don't even
want to lose this pawn for the night
okay so he decides I'm going to play my
Bishop to f5 double attack the knight
all right so there's about 80 people in
the tournament hall here and then you
hear a Big O now what is the Big O all
about after all he is Owen Oh bidding so
what did white played a that caused a
screech here Knight f6 checkmate all
right game over so that's a tough one
for Owen I want to take all right
because black cannot take back because
it's in a absolute pen the Queen would
come and get your King King can't move
there because the knight would get it so
game over now a couple of years before I
had the forethought to put Owen on my
team in a 2-1 to partner tournament okay
because I knew Owen he's pretty
hyperactive guy kind of like myself and
you know he really gets under people's
skin very easily so I knew like you know
you know if we're playing on a team the
guy might be irritated that you know
Owens playing right next to him luckily
my strategy worked out to a tee alright
so in this game I am a white against
Michael Yin I'm about 200 points higher
rated than him all right but that
doesn't mean I'm going to win for sure
all right so the game starts out pretty
pretty normal a 45 Bishop c4 Bishop c5
we got that going good so I decided to
play a little slow c3 probably not the
best way to play because now Knight
comes out to attack my pawn so I cannot
get d4 in without possibly losing my e
pawn so I have to play d3
kind of week all right so black castles
white attacks the bishop here
Bishop moves back a for trying to win
the bishop so black just commonly plays
a five so Knight back Knight takes pawn
so I feel pretty good I want to pawn so
this should be a pretty pretty easy
victory for me get castled we move
around a little bit
Queen f3 right there so Bishop now pins
the night here Bishop e6 protects the
knight Knight out clean there Bishop
takes oh he takes back with the knight
but now I got my Queen kind of caught in
the back there okay but I don't think
he's got a good way to to trap it so I
could take the pawn alright so night
night there so so now his threat might
be Bishop to c8
if I'm not well Bishop C it doesn't even
work because the Queen could just come
down and take the knight so
so I'm alright so I just want to get rid
of the Queen's and have a good game here
okay so negative tax the pawn double
attack so so now he doubles the rook so
now I could take the pawn here but I'm
still a little scared about getting back
row checkmate it possibly down here even
though I probably don't have to be but
it's good to just get it off the table
like you can't back row check making
okay and by this time Owen has lost his
uh his game here so he went old for four
in the day by the way so that's that
book but that's not why I got him as a
partner right I got him to help me when
I'm playing so now Owens Cohen's he's
left the he's left the UH
he's left to turn him at Hall at this
time all right so I take
bishop here so i take take rook now i'm
threatening checkmate here okay
so he's got to be careful here so he
takes and takes so now white is
threatening checkmate right can we all
agree all right so what would you do as
black to stop this checkmate there's a
lot of different moves you can play h 6
h 5 g 6 g 5 f6f-5
are the last one king to f8 you play
King f8 and it stops the rook from
getting the seventh rank and penetrating
your territory okay but unfortunately he
saw hey Mike played g3 that looks kind
of cool so I'll play g6 now it's good to
mirror your opponents okay alright so
now I'm down there rookie 7 so now I'm
feeling pretty good night 2 there now
you're like oh Mike I see a tactic I see
a tactic for you why don't you play rook
here and oh man this Knights in a pen
and you're going to be doing great
why is rook to d7 a losing move for
white alright because of discovered
check I only see I don't see any
discovered checks
oh but after rook to d1 check why is
forced to go here and then you might as
well double as pawns to and insult
injury and take it okay alright so but I
didn't fall for it I'm like all right I
just attack you this way because you got
to attack okay so Brook takes so now
he's offering the knight trade and if
you were paying attention in the last
couple weeks here all right if you're
the higher rated player you do not want
to trade pieces in an endgame okay the
more you can keep on the board the more
chances you'll have for your opponent
either to mess up or more chances you
have to do some cool tricks to them okay
so if we trade at night it won't be
looking good for me
Knight to c6 Knight back to f6 and at
this time Owen comes and usually in a
partner tournament you're sitting next
to your partner okay he decides not to
sit next to me but to sit next to my
opponent and we did not plan this out or
anything
all right so so now I'm feeling good all
right this guy he's due for a mess up
here all right so rook here attacks the
pawn rook check so I got to get up all
right rook goes behind the pawn
so this pawn is a goner pretty much I
guess I could play rook here but it
would be a while so I just take take and
so now I see I think I see a threat here
okay so my rook is attacking f7 right
all right
so who else can come and join the fight
my knight all right
two-on-one all right so I didn't see how
any way that he could protect this but
he makes a counter attack
Knight to d8 all right so now if I take
with the rook he'll play a rook here and
I'm in a lot of trouble
and if I take with the night obviously
he'll take my rook okay Knight takes
Knight takes rook my work is hanging
okay so I attack again all right
rook to e7 and now the unbelievable
happens and all I have to thank is O&O
bidding all right so I'm attacking the
knight obviously just play king of fate
or or something but not rook here okay
and the only reason he would ever play
that is cuz Owen was under his skin so
Rick their check and the game's over all
right so if you're playing in a partner
tournament make sure you get a really
obnoxious partner okay that's basically
what I'm saying all right let's show you
what a an example of what a checkmate
isn't and this is a position from a real
game against a 1300 okay I just played
the move rook here all right and he's he
and he says up isn't that checkmate oh
yeah what what yeah and I'm like no well
first of all you're not even in check so
how is that checkmate all right but a
lot of people think well not many but
hopefully you guys know that all games
over you know my urine Duratec now this
wouldn't even if the the position was
reversed if the rook was over there that
wouldn't be check me because the Queen
could come in block but all right so so
everybody get the point that this is not
checkmate all right I can just escape
okay I can do a lot of things all right
obviously if I take here and rook takes
back cool then it's checkmate but when
it's your turn so it's not checkmate all
right all right good we all got that all
right it's very important in this game
look I'm not going to say the names of
these people because it wasn't an adult
beginner tournament but white turned out
to be one of my best students
because he
really he went to the lessons and he
read a lot of books and he got really
good really fast
okay so white plays d4 all right white
is on my student so he's going to make
some mistakes too but that's okay
so black plays Knight f6 Knight f3 d6
all right III and if you've been
following a III kind of week because it
blocks in this Bishop okay so check not
a good check never a good check when you
can just black with the pawn okay Bishop
here so like most beginners are like
let's attack it again which you really
don't have to you can just proceed as
normal just develop as normal but that's
okay because it blocks out the pin and
this Bishop as you'll see in the game
doesn't do anything for the rest of the
game
so now white perceives normally Bishop
to d3 black castles white does too so so
they're playing okay so far d5 but now
white makes a big mistake
efore I know it's April Fool's Day but
you don't have to be that bad so II for
like Merry Christmas buddy so what's
your black play here adjourn knows thank
you pawn takes e4 so you get the fork
alright but he decides it's too easy
that way we'll play rook to e8 alright
so very typical so if you're thinking
hey oh man I'm not good enough to play
in a beginner tournament come on you are
okay because they're all beginners all
right
so pawn takes pawn takes Bishop pins the
knight that's a tactic you learned pin
the piece so black decides not to do
anything about the pin
so unfortunately white breaks a rule
never capture a pinned piece all right
because it just relieves the pressure so
don't capture pin pieces because look
what it does now it activates his Queen
and gets everything going so now white
saw how well that worked out for him so
he decides I'll pin the other neck
okay so so black plays a six and now
he's like hmm I could take this again or
I'll throw in checkmate rook to e1 all
right free bishop free bishop anybody
want a free bishop no because the rook
would come and checkmate me all right so
it's like I'm going to get out of this
checkmate I just take all right so he's
out of the checkmate
but his white still threatening
checkmate yes Queen to e1 checkmate so
he doesn't want to take he decides to
play Bishop f5 so white gets really
excited he's like oh my God look
checkmate but he's like oh so he ran his
queen all the way down there but he
didn't let his hand off so as I go well
my bishops hanging I might as well get
pulling for it so boom boom so he's on
the comeback so now black makes a very
very tricky move here that is unusual
for a beginner tournament you plays
clean here it's like oh I just moved my
queen over there no big deal but look at
what that did double attack on the
knight pretty interesting Queen Bishop
battery not to be underrated okay so
white somehow sees this I think you just
say hey I'm a nice Abud I just get him
out of here so but better be lucky than
good sometimes right all right now black
could threaten checkmate like this which
is what I would do it's always good to
threaten checkmate
always always yeah always you know it
but um he decides hey instead I just put
my queen here he had so much fun
attacking the knight down there he
thought he could do it down here too so
what he decides I don't want it I want I
want to get my rook on this file he's
playing some hope chess here I hope he
comes and takes a two so I get checkmate
right but then he's like oops oh I
better I better get my Queen out there
all right so so now you decide okay I'll
take a pawn alright he's feeling pretty
good now so now he's like alright enough
of this
checkmate shenanigans alright there is
no way I'm going to get checkmated on
the back row this game so if you had to
guess how do you think black is going to
lose this game is it going to bring his
bishop back here what's going to happen
the possibilities are endless alright so
now you decide to put his nine up here
attack the Queen so he decides move his
Queen it's under attack the Queen trade
white doesn't want any of the Queen
trade so he takes the bishop boom
alright so now White's White's got the
bishop so he's gets a little upset so he
can take now because he doesn't have to
worry about back row checkmate at all
anymore right
alright so white plays a very dubious
move this Bishop is about as junky
bishop as you can get right I mean it
can't move here it can't move there how
is he ever going to even get to play
right so you will never put a good piece
where a bad piece can take it that makes
sense yeah and as an 1800 in our cloud
Jonathan Trent says you can just play
your knight here and even though it's a
sacrifice you can force a checkmate here
alright because there's no way he can
defend all this stuff okay but that's
that's neither here nor there all right
but but the point is look I got all my
pieces over here and you've got nobody
on your Kings side right I got all these
pieces on the Kings side like if I
didn't see a knight here was good right
I would play g4 g5 obviously but on this
this turns out to be really good alright
but the bottom line is you don't want to
trade go to feat pieces for bad pieces
black of course does not play that he
wants to thread a checkmate alright so
he plays Queen to a8 threatening of
course rook to a-1 checkmate right
in his mind that's a checkmate all right
so so why doesn't want any of that he's
like oh my god he's threatening brooked
a1 checkmate I better like Knight to b3
to stop that rook a 1 and now blacks
like up I'm going to remove the defender
of a1 with Queen a3 so the last thing
that he wanted to happen to him actually
happened huh
how does white put the finishing touches
on this game I hate - hey 1 all right
future world champion adjourned Peru
rook to e8 checkmate
game over yeah so you got to protect
your checkmate even if you think you
made a enough room for your King to jump
out he might think Square might be
defended alright so that was a good one
all right so who's ready to make fun of
a chess expert alright so we've seen a
lot of beginners making mistakes but
let's see a chess expert make a mistake
all right
and we're going to be making fun of him
a lot actually so so get ready all right
in this position he was playing one of
his teammates International Master
priyadarshan Kanna pan so we're going to
see a lot of strange moves for black but
if you're weighted in the 2400 or above
you can make a lot of crazy moves and
get away with them because because you
know chess so you can make a lot of
crazy moves all right so white starts
out d for the Queen's pawn black
counters d5 that's that's pretty good so
white plays Bishop f4 highly recommended
by me because II 6 III so you got your
bishop outside of the pawn chain
excellent alright so so far so
good for a for Zack Bishop to d6 attacks
so Queen to g4 attacks the pawn all
right so so black doesn't want to play
g6 here to protect this because hey you
know my bishops out here and it can't go
here all right I probably would play
Queen f6 in this position if I was black
all right but but as I said he's he's an
international master so he can play play
this on northrax unorthodox King f8
all right protects the point this is not
how you want to play though all right
unless you get the 2400 then you can say
hey Mike I can play however I want and
you can all right it's Bishop the d3 and
now black has a discovered attack
everybody know where the discovered
attack is it's when you push a piece
boom you're into attack but not buy the
piece that you just moved so anybody see
oh yeah you see the discovery key fun
very good
so d5 double attack the bishop is now
attacking the Queen and the point is now
attacking the bishop all right so so he
decides to make an attack greater or
equal to the international master so
great because if I move the Queen I lose
my bishop all right so you need to make
a threat greater equal so he plays
Bishop here don't want to do that that's
the last thing and say well take here
all right and now it's X all right Queen
four Queen that's fine that's fine all
right that's all good it's all good yeah
all right but when you when you have
pieces when your opponent has pieces in
your territory it's very easy to catch
him all right the trap all right like is
easier to catch a squirrel on your porch
or in the wild on your porch all right
you're right there you're almost in my
house I'm gonna get you if anybody needs
squirrels remove from the house I'm the
one to call okay I kill no mercy
all right so let's get let's trap them
so is this trapping them no don't even
don't even suggest it is this a good way
to trap it no we don't want to trade a
three-point piece for a three-point
piece when he's in our house all right
we want to let's trap them all right all
right
well once again future world champions
got all the answers all right all right
go for it the worst move ever yes
sometimes it's okay to play the worst
move ever and it is f6 because it leads
the material gain all right so Y can try
in all I see this is when out the game
concluded he didn't try to try to do any
schemes against the international master
but we could try here so do we want to
take with this pawn no because that
would that would let them out boom all
right so let's just take with here and
we don't want to get our pawn ticket so
we play here now what's your black play
the to make make it complete all right
Knight to c6 double attack the bishop
okay I'll play out for you want to just
take my bishop now please please no
we'll just play our Bishop back to d6
what about if I play h3 here you want to
take my bishop now no you never want to
trade a piece that's trapped for a good
active piece does that make sense to
anybody hopefully the answer I'm going
for it yes all right so Bishop there all
right now I'll play my knight up here
I'm attacking your Bishop you want to
move it back to e7 please now I just
take it and then I'll win I'm up a piece
now I got double pawns but I don't care
I'm crushing you okay
all right yes sir oh oh okay okay okay
all right so so in this position instead
of just moving our bishop back we can
just take the knight with check give him
some double isolated pawns and then take
the bishop yeah I totally agree
because it goes with my philosophies
which are good or bad take them as they
are yep you want your poets they have
double isolated pawns and when you're up
you want to trade material excellent I
like it because when when he takes its
check so we don't have to worry about
him escaping right part thank you sir
all right and we're not done with Zack
Stewart just yet all right he had the
good fortune because of his rating to be
on our chests League team all right so
so he made a couple of couple blunders
to end the game here and they both have
something to do with the old back row
checkmate so that's the best way to try
to beat somebody the back row checkmate
like the beginner he thought oh there's
no way I'm going to get back row
checkmate in that game and Zack doesn't
as well all right we're going to speed
through this until the funny part okay
alright alright so Zack is playing white
here alright so this is a u.s. chess
league game all we need it's a basically
a four-on-four competition played over
the Internet
our teams do it pretty well all we need
is a draw to clinch the match a drawer
win does it all right so all Zack has to
do with nat loops and will be asus
alright so black plays rook attacks the
queen and so's XA okay well I could play
Queen takes right and then and then
Queen takes and you know not to gain
nothing lost he decides he sees a tactic
all right about rook takes pawn check
alright so King takes I now I take your
rook and and I'm the best I'm up upon
look at me journey even thinks it's a
bad move that's when you know you're not
playing at expert strength alright so
what would black play here Oh adjourns
dying to say let's give somebody else a
try here
Queen f1 checkmate yep
alright so unfortunately rook takes g7
King takes so it always sees hey I can't
do it I can't take he took it way too
fast then he it kind of like entered lol
and sent a message to me so so I can't
take it alright so I'll play a Queenie
one all right that stops the mate Queen
up three check and then King here and
then rook the d1 pretty much seals the
day okay so so that was good a black
even though he's up a lot to just punish
them when you're up alright get the
Queen get the quick win alright so
itzhak decided we'll give him one more
chance okay let's see let's see let's
see if he redeems himself here a lot of
people might think he does here alright
it's it's looking pretty good for him
we'll speed through the opening it's
immaterial to the lesson
alright so lots of backroad checkmates
going on here
zach is playing white once again all
right oh no no excuse me
zach is black alright and in this
position plays h6 all right so we've
seen how this works you play eight six
you're never going to get checkmated if
you play h6 okay if there's one thing
you should learn from this lesson
it's that does anybody believe me no
just cuz you play h6 doesn't mean you're
not going to get back row checkmated
okay a lot of people think well don't
have to worry about that no more
help you'll see you'll see all right so
so white plays the move like everybody
see this position alright so white has
one two three four five six points two
three
so white looks like he's just crushing
alright alright
so Zacks really not doing all that well
but he's got he's got some like hey I'm
going to checkmate you and now he plays
f3 which almost every mean just like it
has white lost his mind
you can't even stop these checkmates
anymore right right he can't even he
can't even stop them
alright so so first thing Jack should
have realized in this position is hey if
somebody is going to give you a gift
alright sometimes a Trojan horse alright
yeah like you know just watch out
oh yeah okay I think that just slipped
out they're here all right
all right so so Zack decides I'm taking
the pawn okay I'm going to checkmate you
in one move and there's nothing you can
do about it all right so you see how
there's no way for for white to
successfully stopped this checkmate here
all right
rook here loses the rook right
how else can you stop g2 all right so
when you're in desperate situations you
got to check all right so which way do
we want to check we could check with the
rook or we could we don't want to go to
a it because of the bishop or we could
go to c8 if we're not 100% precise about
this move we lose so little does act
know in this position white is actually
has mate in three in this position yeah
it's a tough one
because he didn't just give away his
pawn for nothing especially it's like I
give you a pawn and I give you an easy
chance at checkmate Mei and three main
four doesn't matter mm-hmm it's got to
be made soon enough all right so so
let's let's try to get a consensus here
we want to check with the Queen or the
rook because we got a check right
anybody got any guesses all right Peter
says rook yeah if you have a if you have
a you know debate look this rook isn't
really doing anything this is all he can
do right so you might as well have them
do it because the Queen can do other
stuff as you'll see King aged seven all
right so so this is a good thing to do
at home and everywhere when you're
playing chess is you want to count out
how many checks you have and go over
each and every single one of them
like if somebody says it's made in three
main four main two just look at your
checks and then start going over each
and every variation kind of how many
checks you have like in this position
you have one two three checks I count
you can Queen takes here Queen check or
rook check okay and as silly as they
look I mean one of them is going to lead
to checkmate believe it or not and I'll
give you a hint and it has to do with a
pin one of these pieces over here are
going to be in a pin and then you're
going to win adjurned thinks he has it
but I don't know does everybody else
think so so if Queen to g6 check pawn
can take if Queen check pawn can take
what so anybody got a guess
besides adjourn
Peter all right well we might as well
just throw it out there work today Jake
King takes all right so he's feeling
pretty good man I got a lot of stuff
going all right so so what can you tell
me about this pawn it's in a pen it's in
an absolute pin when pawns are in pins
they can't do what they usually do like
is this really protecting this no all
right adjourn Queen takes h6 check King
to g8 Queen takes g7 checkmate
exploiting the pin all right so that's a
really good combination that you can you
can use in your games now okay so just
because your opponent played h6
or g6 or g3 to stop a backward checkmate
don't give up on the background check
mate all right it's the easiest way to
win chess games a great book to read is
Bobby Fischer teaches chest we sell it
up here for like 795 the first book I
ever read and one of the only ones and
it's one of the best for sure as you can
tell but I don't get back real
checkmated very often all right so we
got one more game all right so I got the
white pieces against a guy who never
played chess before okay so do you like
my chances all right so ii for d5 this
was his very first tournament all right
so pawn takes but it kind of builds on
last week's lesson alright so when you
played e5e5e5 - and lands on the same
rank as a your pawn you have the choice
to do one percent alright so let's do it
all right
so he doesn't know what just happened so
so he plays Knight f6 so pawn takes
check King up so things are going well
just keep checking now I can't Castle
not that heap I knew what that meant
anyway so Knight up three Castle it gets
us Bishop out I get another check he
goes there
Bishop check so its Kings got to go here
so now it's a discovered check should we
go here no here no just take a piece
when it and they can't take back because
it's a discovered check alright it might
as well throw one more check in there
alright King to g6 Bishop takes so now
he wants to prove that he learned how
the pawn moves now I can take diagonally
so he plays h6 but I get my knight in
attack the Queen so now he just he just
asked me to take his queen now he just
says take it like just take it so what
move do I do
- just take it anybody besides adjourn
it builds on look the rook the knight
and the Queen all in the same line so
all I have to do is move my knight and
the Queen is under attack
how can you freeze pieces and chests yes
from the back
you got the right piece you got the
right things
unfortunately we take the pawn then a
always Queen can move and it's not
frozen we want to freeze the Queen so
the only way to freeze pieces in chess
is to check the King so where should we
check the king with the knight should we
play it to f8 no all right adjourned
you're dying over here
Knight to f4 check good oh but he just
Oh free free NATO crowd goes wild but
nope I always take back with the night
the night on the back row it's very
strong Queen check now I just eat up the
pieces all right
so if you were paying attention from
last week never give up never surrender
what should black do to try to just I
know I'm down everything I'm down
everything like if you put it in a chest
base he's down by three touchdowns 21
points here all right but hey he wants
that he wants to win this game right
that's why he came to do it came to win
so what movie do you think he plays
because he wants to win the game rook to
e8 threatening the back row checkmate
you know how mad that made me like how
dare he I'm crushing you how dare you
checkmate me h3 we'll get to it check
first you got to check check him again
now he pins his rook though so that was
a lad well that's all I could do
so Knight here King there if I was
really good I would have just brought my
knight here so I wouldn't get check but
but I play h3 I allow these checks to
happen and then it gets pretty bad from
here now this is the this is the best
way to get out your rook if you're
paying attention at home always get your
book out
that it's awesome alright alright so
I've seen I've shown a lot of uh people
being a foolish today so I have to show
myself because even the best of them act
like fools once a year all right hey if
you can believe it if you can believe it
so the opening of this game is not yeah
yeah so so this was a game I played I
was a the black pieces here I was in a
lot of trouble alright so so I played my
knight to d8 because I don't want to get
checkmated so Brook takes all right and
now this guy he's not a fool but he acts
like a fool in this position what what
move do you think he makes that he slams
as hard as he can is like dude you are
done a queen age sex yeah it was like
yeah I play this move in a second as I
ain't going out like this I ain't going
out like no fool but but now what's
blacks response because this is a pretty
pretty tough tough thing to defend Queen
to g7 checkmate
all right but luckily luckily I figured
it out well I do it going into it so I
was able to play it as far as hard as he
played his move so any guesses how how
was how was black going to save the day
here cuz can this rook help defend g7
know the LightSquared bishop this guy
so who's the only possible player that
could ever help stop g7 the Queen good
alright but does you have a magic way to
get to get over here to protect f8 she
does have a magic way and she doesn't
get one jump a game or nothing
so queen ac5 Chuck all right so that's
one of the reasons why I say f6 is a bad
move because you're usually castled over
there and you know it's same thing you
move the F pawn you're susceptible to
checks all right so you can only play
King h1 Queen to f8 and now he's like oh
man because he could just trade off
everything but then he's got no attack
and he's down upon in a in an endgame
okay so Queen here Queen h4 so double
attack on my rook
so I'm winning now so I take the uh take
the bishop show you take back with the
rook and keep his pawns all in a nice
Island no because remember the back row
checkmate so now it's like alright I got
rid of my backward checkmate problems
but my pawns are all junk so if I go
into an endgame I'm just going to smoke
this guy all right but unfortunately I
have to get there first
all right so I decide against my better
judgment at the time too I decide I'm
gonna play my rook down here and really
try to try to checkmate him you know why
not you know all right so he decides Oh
attack your rook like no big deal Oh
somebody sees it is somebody sick so so
some moves look obvious like all right
he's he played made his Bishop here to
attack my rook but some moves have
double meanings all right do more than
one thing all right
dual purpose moves so it's true he's
attacking my rook but he's also he's
also doing something pretty slick here
okay so when I'm like oh look the new
hit the c8 what move does he knew the
threat checkmate here if you don't see
it I don't blame you cause hey you know
I didn't see it either there's no way
you see
all right so so so if you're having
trouble finding this move like I have no
idea how is he going to threaten
checkmate first you have to ask yourself
if Y could play any move all right
like in blog house where you can just
place pieces where would he place one of
the pieces on the board legally or
illegally to instrument a checkmate
anybody have that answer
all right he would need US Queen to h8
and that would be checkmate
unfortunately like we say Queens don't
jump over pieces so where would his
Queen go yeah yeah f6 Thanks f6 yeah
that's a bummer huh so all I can do is
take this take another pawn and then
give up because I ran out of checks and
there's no way to stop Queen 2h a
checkmate okay so so let's just say I
was really smart and I saw okay he
played Bishop to e5 and he attacked my
rook let's say I still don't want to
lose a Brooke even though I have this
point I don't even care but let's say I
really don't want to lose this rook
where should I put this rook to save him
and prevent the checkmate yes adjourned
b6 thank you and then I could go on and
hopefully win the game but you never
know alright so so that's me being a
fool so everybody everybody is a fool
some more than others as we saw by that
but yeah so hopefully in your next games
you won't be making silly mistakes or
else you're going to be see yourself up
here one day next year so so let's say
let's try not to do that